all right Catherine is with us in New
Jersey starting off this hour hi
Catherine how are you good how are you
there better than I deserve what's up
great um so I am currently on baby stuff
number two and trying to pay off debt
and I'm wondering if you have some sort
of cap on what a parent should pay on
extracurricular activities just some
background my husband and I my husband
make sixty-two thousand dollars a year I
make one hundred and ten thousand
dollars a year we have twenty five
thousand dollars in credit card debt ten
thousand dollars that he owes on taxes
and my $60,000 worth of student loans
right now we have three children and we
are currently paying about forty four
hundred dollars a year for dance so I'm
trying to justify this 4444 hundred
dollar bill now that we're trying to
eliminate that and I'm wondering if you
think that's too much should there be a
cop do I pull the kid what's your
opinion on that well I think what you've
got to ask yourself is can you achieve
your goals of getting your finances
under control while continuing this and
I'm gonna let you decide that obviously
but you know what I heard was I spent
forty four hundred dollars on dance and
I didn't pay my ten thousand dollar tax
bill well that I that cannot continue
that's absurd
right and so we have to make
arrangements out of your one hundred and
seventy two thousand dollar income to
get the rest this mess cleaned up to
even consider continuing this and you
have to be able to if you're gonna
continue it while you're cleaning up the
mess you have to clean up the mess at
breakneck speed and so you know like III
you know like a lot of what you
mentioned should be gone in a year with
your income twenty five thousand ten
thousand you know those kinds of numbers
should go away making a hundred and
seventy two
in one year agreed oh great okay so you
guys have been out of control
disorganized weren't watching what the
flip you were doing and you woke up and
went oh crap we got to stop this well
good that's a good move that's a really
good move and so getting on a written
budget with you and your husband but
don't tell me that you're going on
vacation or going out to eat while you
owe the IRS $10,000 right and if you're
gonna continue dance at some level maybe
not the level it is now but at some
level you've got to you've got to
justify that by cutting deeper into your
lifestyle in other areas but you've got
a bunch of that and you make a bunch of
money and so you should clean it up you
agree with that because you've already
started right we've started it's just I
I guess you get into this defense mode
where then you just want to start
slashing everything aside to me feels
good because the kids aren't responsible
for the mess that we're in right so well
they're not responsible for it but they
didn't live there they're you know
they're not responsible for you getting
taken to jail for not paying your taxes
but that can happen if you don't pay
your taxes so you need to do that you
know so you know I agree that but you
know they're not responsible for your
career but it's going to affect where
the the type of car they get when they
turn 16 so yeah it's not it's not their
fault they shouldn't be punished so to
speak I get I get your sentiment there
but the other thing is this and you know
what happened was Sharon and I we went
through this stuff was we had to ask
ourselves okay where does our children's
future
come from and dr. Megan Meeker talks a
lot about that it doesn't come from the
dance recital or the soccer field it
doesn't come from travel hockey their
future it doesn't come from piano
expertise you know 1% or less of our
kids make a living in any of those areas
and so what are they learning in those
things well they've got an activity
they're out there moving they're
learning social skills they're
they're getting some physical fitness
they're learning some character but
really what we had to realize was you
know we're we're we're gonna grow our
character at home with our kids
so I'll give you an example my son
Daniel played ice hockey his whole
childhood I coached him some of the time
I played when I was a kid but we had the
opportunity to spend 10,000 dollars a
year more for him to play travel hockey
now he was a pretty good hockey player
in a rec level rec league in Nashville
Tennessee okay he held his own upper
part of his class so to speak would have
been an all-star or whatever it wasn't
the best player on the team but he
wasn't the worst player on the team we
didn't know however fairly certainly
based on his skill level he was not
going to play in the NHL so spending an
extra ten thousand dollars for a
ten-year-old to travel did not make
sense in our budget
and so you know that it's not his future
career it means we're gonna be away from
home a bunch more and we're spending
money we don't have at that time we
didn't have that money and and so we
just very easily said you're playing rec
leaf league and so you know one of the
girls was a competition cheerleader and
you know we're spend a lot of money for
this kid to flip and so you know it had
to had to be dialed back number of flips
you're gonna do I guess it's gonna be
smaller you know I don't know because I
didn't think she's gonna flip for a
living I just didn't think that was
gonna happen so um you know the
competition cheerleading thing we went
through that so we've we've faced these
same things at the Remzi house at
different stages of our ability to pay
for it and so you just got to judge it
and go I'm gonna use some common sense
for this oh and by the way whether or
not you're in a dance recital when
you're seven probably does not dictate
your future it really shouldn't if
you're doing your job with raising your
kids it's just a nice thing it's okay
but it really shouldn't dictate who you
become in the future and so you've just
got a you know activities versus
character and Meg Meeker talks a lot
about this stuff and strong father
strong daughters in hero in all of our
parenting books and she's really really
on point on
so again I'm not telling you not to do
this I'm not saying you're a bad parent
if you did we did some of it but just
use some common sense and be sure you
hit your other goals if you're not
hitting your other goals and you're not
hitting them rapidly then that needs to
be cut out but do you have to do it
making 172,000 now if you tell me you're
making 40,000 and you're spending 4400
on dance I'm like you're done you can't
do it that ratio is off but you make so
stinking much money you oughta be able
to do both if you watch what you're
doing and make it your goal here it's a
good discussion thanks for letting me
have it with you thanks for calling you